thank you very much
good morning everybody welcome to this
joint audit and standards committee
i am counselor dave muller and i am
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements
one please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
two that you do not interrupt other
speakers
three that if you are attending the
meeting just attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
and fourthly please ensure your mobile
phones are on silent or switched off
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have con
sent into being filmed by entering this
meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i know like to make some introductions
the officers attending the meeting today
are
emily yule the monitoring officer
catherine steele
assistant director for corporate
resources melissa evans
corporate manager financial services and
commissioning and procurement
rebecca hewitt assistant manager
financial accountant
and john snell the corporate manager for
internal audit
can i now move to the agenda please
uh item one is apologies for absence
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor
castin thank you very much thank you
item number two
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary
interests by members are there any to
declare please
no okay i'd like to move then to item
three which is jsat jake jack
2012 confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the joint audit and standards
committee held on the 25th of january
2021
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes please
okay could i have a proposal and a
second to please
counselor haran yes chair i can propose
them i've read them and they seem
accurate reflection thank you thank you
very much and a second to please
counselor mccraw
happy to second chair thank you very
much uh i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you mandy thank you chair if you
could go
to um the modern.gov app
um click on the plus sign the
vote should be in progress
[Music]
i think a chair that's all votes
received and that's unanimously for
thank you very much indeed mandy thank
you i'd now like to move on to
item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received chair thank you uh item
five questions by the public i'm
received
thank you very much and item six
questions by councillors
i'm received thank you very much i now
like to move on to
um item number seven and
this is the jac 2013
managing the risk of fraud and
corruption annual report 2021
and i will now invite jon snell the
corporate manager
internal audit to present the report
thank you john
thank you chair good morning uh
councillors
excuse me i seem to be suffering at the
moment not quite sure why perhaps it's
the uh the nice weather that we're
experiencing um so this report outlines
the
current arrangements in place across
both councils to ensure there is a
proactive corporate approach to
preventing fraud and corruption
and also provides details of the
proactive work undertaken during the
year
whilst it's not primarily a role of
internal audit function to
detect fraud it does have a role in
providing an independent assurance on
the effectiveness of the processes put
in place by management to manage
to manage the risk of fraud and
obviously where necessary we will
investigate the causes of fraud and
allegations of
fraud the annual audit plan which i'll
talk about in the next paper
has an allowance for internal audit to
undertake
regularity audits investigations this is
around the national fraud initiative
related work
and proactive anti-fraud and corruption
work
the number of days allocated in my
opinion is deemed to be proportionate to
the identified risk of fraud within the
councils and is supported by senior
management
the planning process is further
supported through the fraud risk
register
which contains a list of areas
where we myself and corporate managers
believe that the councils could be
susceptible to fraud
the register also helps manage managers
focus on the suitable internal controls
to mitigate any subsequent risk
to provide some context around general
fraudulent activity
in local government sit for produce
annual national statistics
based on return surveys which we are
part of
which indicate the total value of fraud
identified
and prevented during 2019-20
and then it was deemed to be
approximately about 240 million
the report shows that council tax
continued to be the largest area of
identified fraud
for councils with more than 30 000
cases totaling 36 million during
2019-20 the two highest perceived
uh fraud risk areas uh for last year
1920
are again procurement and council tax
single persons discount
of our work includes raising awareness
across the councils
and includes examples such as alerting
staff of national fraud bulletins
and ensuring that the related internal
controls are present
and operating effectively subscription
to the national fraud network which
provides
proactive intelligence of potential
fraud and error risks
the councils through the shared revenues
partnership continue to give out a
strong message
about fraud in both publicly issued and
internal documents regarding
council tax and housing benefit claim
forms
fair processing notices which inform the
public that we will use their data
for the prevention and detection of
crime have been updated as part of the
general data protection regulations
we also attend uh or have attended the
organized fraud and intelligence group
webinar which took place in february
this year
to alert the councils to fraud trends
nationally and attending sit for
internal fraud webinars in march
again this year to explore and further
strengthen internal controls to mitigate
fraud
uh both councils excuse me both councils
are
committed to being open and transparent
and the communities and local
authorities
code of recommended practice for local
authorities on data transparency
has set out publishing requirements on
local authorities
and this includes publishing information
on each council's cash flow
work to help
fight fraud uh con corruption locally
across suffolk
we've nominated a representative to sit
on the suffolk counter fraud group
it's intended to hold its meetings uh
normally about three to four months
although obviously that's been slightly
scuppered by kovid19
but they have regular contact with one
another across suffolk
and their main objectives are set out in
this report
council's shared revenues partnership
continued to perform extremely well
and the team have been recognised by the
department for working pensions
for their work to reduce fraud and error
in housing benefit payments
in processing what's termed as verif
verify earnings and pensions
vep alerts the partnership authorities
are amongst the top performing in the
country with performance rates of
just over 98 for baber and almost 97 for
mid suffolk
uh during 1819 the team have also been
thanked by the dwp
for their continuous efforts in tackling
fraud and error across the districts
and also being asked to work with them
to develop best practice
which is really encouraging
until excuse me internal audit continued
to take a leading role in the national
fraud initiative
and workers started investigating
identified matches for the latest
exercise
work on housing investigations these are
detailed in paragraph
3.25 to 3.27
for further information sadly
frauds fraudsters are exploiting the
covid19 pandemic in order to carry out
fraud and cybercrime
and in response we've issued alerts to
our residents to help minimize the risk
of becoming
a victim of such frauds and cyber crime
as you know the government is providing
grant funding through local authorities
to support businesses
and a member of the internal audit team
is supporting the business center
to provide a level of assurance that
funds are only paid to
eligible businesses and ensuring that
appropriate action is taken to recover
any frauds or
any funds that are being paid out
fraudulently
or in error the auditor will continue to
focus on the end-to-end process of the
business
grants funding from receipt of
application to issue of payment
and any post-event assurance undertaken
this work
will continue while the grants are
available
in terms of what we found to date only
one grant application has been paid an
error and that happened
within baby district council officers
sought immediate legal advice from
shared legal services
and after some investigation was
reported to action fraud and the
national anti-fraud network through
networking with their local authorities
it was identified that another council
had received the same fraudulent
application so it just goes
to show in terms of collaboration and
working and networking how benefit
that can be across the country as a
whole
no other frauds have been identified
however the recent nfi matching data
matching exercise
may identify organized national frauding
activities
and we'll keep watching rely on that in
terms of looking ahead and against again
a backdrop of reduced fundings we need
to assess fraud risks effectively
and target resources where they'll
produce most benefit
excuse me again we obviously need to
remain particularly alert to the threat
of fraud
uh as as a result of the 19 impact which
i've sort of touched upon earlier
are there any questions to this part of
the fraud
this report please thank you very much
um john
um can i ask members do any members have
any questions for
um john snl please thank you
um councillor mclaren please
thank you can you hear me sorry
can you hear me yes um i feel sorry
asking john any questions because he
sounds if he's struggling a bit but
i've got two questions john
first of all i want to say how
comprehensive i thought the report was
and found it very interesting but i just
want to refer to
page 13 3.12
about the suffolk counter fraud group um
presumably that is an officer that is
the representative on the group
from our councils that's correct yes
do we do we do we as a group
uh guess any reports from that
particular group
not at this stage no counsellor it's
relatively
new as a group they have met a few times
obviously covert 19 has had an impact in
terms of how regularly they do meet
but the whole the benefit that we gain
is actually sharing knowledge right
across suffolk
so as i said each authority has a
nominated member
we share information what's coming up we
help one another particularly we're
working closely with israel
and that's around the srp stuff but also
the code of 19
business payments so we've been working
very closely with them and sharing
information which
has proved beneficial uh um to both
parties
um but it's also about showing in best
practice what each authority is doing
and whether we can bake steal or borrow
from others and likewise they can do the
same from us
but it's a very useful form to meet
share ideas and particularly how to move
this forward
so we can actually be far more proactive
than we have been in the past
thank you and can i ask you another
question yes certainly
thank you um 3.26 where you're given the
scale of the incidents um
given that the majority perhaps the
fraud
might come within the housing um
remit and tenant services team are
obviously the ones who investigate that
do they have enough resources given the
enormous workload they've had over the
past year
do they have the resources to actually
undertake those investigations
thank you yeah yeah thank you kenz
yeah it's a good question the current
climate obviously um
the pandemic has caused a number of
issues because
in terms of protecting not only the
tenants but also staff from actually
entering into
the homes themselves so um talking to
the the housing managers i think there's
a sense that they do have enough staff
um at the moment but in terms of
identifying potential uh fraudulent
activity by tenant
obviously it's made it quite difficult
because of the pandemic
um but we are remaining or they are
remaining quite vigilant
and investigating the resources i think
are okay they've not suggested
to me at any stage that they're being
overwhelmed with particular fraud and
activity in terms of tenancy fraud
whether they're subletting or they're
not using the home as the principal home
if you like so
i haven't got any sense that they're
being overwhelmed with the work but
nevertheless they
do remain very vigilant thank you john
thank you chair thank you very much
occasional mclaren thank you john for
that answer
we now have counselor matheson please
thank you chair um in light of council
mccarran's
um question there about the suffolk
group
um should we perhaps add that to our um
forward plan at some point um i think
presumably if something comes to light
within our two councils we'll hear about
it anyway
um but it might be of interest at some
point to
to pick up um any particular frauds
or you know for members to hear about
any particular frauds
um that are taking place in other parts
of the county
i mean yes certainly um council is
something we can do and as i said
normally i would report
um annually to this council in terms of
fraud
if i from the personal point of view if
i felt that there was some issues
particularly for baby suffolk that
needed to be addressed
and i felt that we didn't have the
resources and that would be something
that obviously i would be talking to
um emily and also catherine as a section
151 officer
in terms of obviously the responsibility
she has
um at this stage as i said
it's not something that i would normally
bring back
um ad hoc other than through the annual
report but if councillors felt
and i suppose if i felt that there was
sufficient concern
in terms of resources available to me to
undertake
fordham to work then perhaps then i
could come back to
both chairs and seek their advice at an
initial stage
yeah i was only thinking in terms of of
maybe a paragraph specific
specifically about that in in the annual
fraud report
okay um unless obviously there's
something absolutely red hot
comes up in which case we'd want to hear
about it thank you
certainly council i can do that yeah
thank you thank you very much councillor
matheson
um do any other members have any
questions for
um uh counselor mccraw please
thank you chair uh i keep trying to find
this paragraph
john during your uh report you you
mentioned some performance figures
for baber in mid suffolk around the
level of 98
and 97 percent um i i wonder i think
looking in the report i can see in 315
performance rates of 99 and a half for
baber and 100
for mid suffolk uh am i is there some
disparity there or am i looking at
different figures here
uh let's have a look at a councillor
315 has 99 and a half and a hundred
yeah you're you're quite right
well spotted yeah yeah i think the
actual figures
i i think i'm aware of this now um i had
some revised figures
um from srp um and i think
the figures in paragraph
318
uh sorry 315. so that those figures are
correct the 315
figures are correct but they are in fact
for 20 19
20 so they could get regarded as
requiring updating
yes yes certainly the other point i
noted
looking at the total value of um
claims for housing benefit and other
points where there's been overpayment
and looking at the number of cases and
the total impact and this i just ask you
to confirm this
it would appear to me that the actual
amounts involved in individual cases
would be in a range of perhaps less than
100 pounds
up to less than 200 pounds each case
i mean they are relatively speaking
small
amounts yes which could in fact be
be simple error on behalf of a system
you know it's not
it's not as though there's the average
size
of any of these is large no that's
that's correct that's correct
uh councillor thank you thank you very
much counselor mccraw do any other
members of this committee have any
further questions for
um
are there any other questions from other
members present who whose members are
not actually members of this committee
please
no then i will then open the item up for
debate
uh please use the raised hand function
if you wish to
raise something during debate are there
any members that wish to debate this
item
can't see any hands okay
thank you very much everybody the
recommendation
is that the contents of this report
detailing the progress made ensuring
there are effective arrangements and
measures in place across both councils
to minimize the risk of forward
corruption be noticed so there's no
actual vote on this one
so thank you john for that report i
therefore like to move on to agenda item
number eight the internal audit plan for
2122
and can i know please invite john snell
the corporate manager for internal audit
to present his report for this please
thank you john
again thank you chad uh excuse me um
the purpose of this report is to provide
members with details of the audit plan
for next year the scope of those audits
to be undertaken
and the corporate activities that will
be supported through the work of the
team
as we move forward the plan
has been developed to ensure it delivers
against the public sector internal audit
standards
in that it covers the following
activities
governance processes ethical issues
around accountability integrity honesty
information technology governance how
the it
infrastructure supports enables us as an
organization to achieve its priorities
and risk management and fraud management
which
as i said we just touched upon in the
previous report
the planning process also recognizes
that the councils
are striving still striving to improve
services
and use innovative approaches in
delivering services
against a backdrop of reducing funds
and therefore have directed resources
using a risk-based approach
to maximize the effectiveness of
internal control
the construction of the audit plan has
been developed to support both the
annual government statement which will
come later
in the year and the council's key
strategic themes
in developing the plan we've assessed
the following areas
which is include review of each
council's strategic priorities
contained in the corporate plan and
those outcomes
that support them the significant and
operational risk registers
including any specific covid19 related
risks identified
engagement with senior management to
identify management's
view of the coming year's risks related
to the corporate plan and delivery
programs
about which assurance is required and
consideration
of the 2021-22 budget to evaluate levels
of income and expenditure
value of assets volume transactions et
cetera
interest to internal audit that's around
about the level of passed audited
opinions recommendations made
were implemented fraud risks values and
complexities around
transactions etc and also around the
control assurance
in respect of the three lines of defense
which is around sound management of
frontline operations
uh oversight management activity within
professional framework
and external review by internal audit
sorry internal assurance providers
the audit plan will continue to be
resourced from existing staff
and from an external audit partner this
arrangement still
allows a direct internal provision plus
the commission of external skills and
capacity and provides a blend of
resources
from within the councils and from an
external partner
of services the covid19 emergency
and management directive to
re-prioritize work during
uh the last quarter this last quarter um
has had a
a significant impact on the internal
audit resources and its ability to
deliver
normal internal audits during this year
as a result i've agreed with management
to defer a number of audits into this
year's plan so you will see that
they've been brought forward these will
be reported in
in more detail in my annual internal
audit report 2021 later in the year
the 534 audit days
work proposed in the plan is structured
to reflect the the audit disciplines
undertaken to
support delivery of the governance and
professional framework
uh the resources committed to each
category is annotated in
detail in the plan annex a and also
summarized
within appended
the intention is that as far as possible
the proposed audits within the plan will
be undertaken
however it's recognized that the plan
needs to be flexible
to respond to changing circumstances on
the emerging risks
and therefore um it's best to say that
this is a statement of intent
in terms of the plan that's presented
here
the plan as uh presented an annex a
uh represents uh my current view of how
resources can be
um most effectively used uh
whether significant deviations to the
plan are required then these will be
reported back to this committee
as appropriate and therefore
satisfied that the level uh and the mix
of resources together the errors covered
in the audit plan
uh will enable me to provide an annual
internal audit opinion
a year end and there are no additional
audit related issues
currently i think that probably need to
be brought to the detention
of this morning's meeting so i'm again
happy to take
questions on the report thank you very
much john
do any members have any questions for
john on this report
thank you councillor mclaren please and
then councillor matthison
sorry i've been a bit difficult with the
technology
um in relation to john in relation to
page 26 4.3 what one
um you act as the um
deputy monitoring officer that's
that's cool yeah yeah uh looking at the
days that you've
allocated for that given that
the monitoring officer i think has put a
lot of effort into a lot of meetings
recently
i've been aware of the very large input
she's had
do you think that 49 days is sufficient
to support the monitoring officer
um yeah it's a very good question
councillor um i think so i mean
obviously i discussed this with emily as
the monitor council's monitoring officer
um i'm a deputy monitoring officer
there's also another deputy monitoring
officer
um so um this there's effectively three
of us although the bulk of the work was
already would be carried out by emily
she will delegate um work as she sees
fit to to myself and
my colleagues so i think in terms of
resources i think we're
we're fairly resilient uh in terms of
undertaking this work
yeah thank you and now just one more
question john yes sir i'm sorry my
question is coming too
um uh in relation to page 29 about the
proposed audit plan last year
i was concerned i think it was last year
i was concerned about
part of the procurement process we felt
there wasn't enough
monitoring of contracts do you think
that you've addressed that now in this
proposed
internal audit plan yes certainly and i
remember your
your question um from past uh
councillors so
um this is an area that
we had hoped to undertake the work um
for during
this year but as a result of the
um the east of england lga's report we
were waiting for that
that didn't come through and obviously
um melissa's
on here as well so she can correct me if
i've got the dates wrong but
that report didn't come in until quite
late again that was subject to the
pandemic and the issues surrounding that
so i've spoken to to melissa when i was
building up and developing the plan and
we agreed
that we would carry forward those
numbers of days i think about 25 days
over to this year in terms of
procurement
it is an important area and what we're
hoping to do is having a look at this
external report
look at what recommendations uh are
coming out
there will be a period of embedment
clearly but we will almost do then a
health check
against those recommendations sometime
next year
and that will be in terms of timing that
will be agreed with melissa and her team
thank you john thank you chair thank you
thank you mclaren councillor matheson
please
thank you chair um yeah regarding the
monitoring officer
deputy role um are you liaising with
with with the monitoring officer and the
other deputy
so that we don't find ourselves ever in
the situation where there is not
one monitoring officer available um i
realize that's less of a problem
um now that emily is not on maternity
leave but
uh there was there was a particularly
uncomfortable situation that did arise
um 18 months or something again now just
to get
reassurance that that that's actually
being i think it was all to do with
fridays in particular yeah
thank you um both myself and the other
deputy monitoring officer
and emily we um well both myself and
jan who's the deputy manager we report
to emily
and any leave that's required has to be
authorized by emily and
so we always ensure that we will have
borrowing sickness etc that we will have
sufficient
resources available five days a week
so there should not be any occasion
where
uh a member of the public or a
councillor can't get hold of either
emily myself or my colleague the other
deputy monitoring officer
so we have coverage five days a week
thank you
can may i have another chair yes you're
sure okay
um yeah i you'll remember i have asked
before about this
a certain anxiety about the
the internal audit staffing
accepting that the the internal sorry
the external resource
is particularly of value that you you as
you said
could you just run us through what
staffing we've actually got
um on the payroll so to speak
at the moment yeah we have two two ftes
that's myself
and a colleague who said it full time
and the other is supported by the
external
provider thank you chair
thank you can i just bring in emily
ewell please the um you had your hand
raised emily
thank you chair i just wanted to um come
in to support
um john's answer to uh the question
around coverage for the for the
monitoring officer
um and just to confirm that as john has
described we do
um organize leave and coordinate leave
to ensure
that in most cases there there is always
a monitoring officer or a deputy
available to answer any queries um if on
the very rare occasion
um it it does so happen that we all need
to take leave on the same
day um the executive assistance team
always has a
an emergency contact number for us so if
there is a very urgent
um query and we're not somebody's not in
the office we can always be contacted so
i just wanted to provide that
reassurance that there would always be
coverage
for urgent queries chair thank you thank
you very much emily thank you
um can i move on to counselor haran
please
yes thank you chair um john i was
intrigued by sort of item five
you know on the the workload there's
something about doing
making sure people do the right things
in the right way at the
right time and for the right reasons
is this led by you john or are you
called in if
um management think something needs
doing in a certain place
i just wonder if you expand on how this
is led
and it just strikes me you would need a
close amount of expertise and you
probably have got that john but um
with so many departments across the
whole um
council i was just intrigued how you
sort of go about doing that
and just a supplementary question i see
you've got planning enforcement but
you haven't got planning um on on the
workload and i just wondered why
okay yeah thank you councillor um
there is a a sort of fairly robust um
process in developing the the audit plan
and much of that is centered around
having conversations particularly with
senior management
and also peers corporate managers like
myself
and part of that process is to have
those individual conversations with them
and go through
the areas of concern that they may have
or as i sort of alluded to
looking at the significant risk
registers the operational registers
and having a a sort of a really quite
candid conversation
i think we have a very good relationship
internal audit with management
in terms of that they're quite happy to
share their concerns with me
we're not as many years ago we're not
deemed to be the police come knocking at
your door we're very much here
to work alongside with management to
provide more efficient services
um and so therefore we can have these
very meaningful conversations as we
develop the audit plan
so as you can appreciate we've got
scarce resources too
so i have to do a risk-based assessment
on the
areas that we want to have a look at as
much as i'd like to cover everything i
don't obviously have those resources so
it is a risk based approach management
also have responsibility
for ensuring that their areas of service
delivery have
robust controls if they feel that they
need
internal audits in sight they will come
knocking at my door
and subject to obviously availability
and the risks associated with the
concern they may have
then that's where i've sort of referred
to that that plan becomes very flexible
so there might be new risks emerging
that i have to drop off some audits
because in terms of the scoring
it's even less of a risk and during the
year
i set the plan at the beginning of the
year but as we sort of progress through
the year
those risks might change and therefore i
have to take a reflective look in terms
of is it still
relevant to undertake that order and
then that comes through conversations
again with management
so it's a very robust process that we go
through
in developing that um that plan but with
the caveat that it does obviously need
to remain very flexible
as we address risks
sorry there was a second part to your
question wasn't there sort of counsellor
yes i just wondered you've got planning
enforcement not planning
they're just a supplementary john i
presume you would flag up staff
shortages
in one department or one area that you
were concerned about as well is that
correct
yeah absolutely so um much of the work
that we tend to do is
holistic so there are numbers so yes we
would focus on the key controls within
service areas but there's also the it
issues there's also about um the
the data the quality of the data um
what's its input and the output
so it's it's a whole host of areas that
we would look at
rather one specific uh area within a
service
hopefully that answers your question
counselor
and and planning
planning well i've spoken to um
obviously tom uh i've also spoken to
phil is bell at the moment and it was
felt it was actually
phil having had those conversations that
wanted um some work around planning
enforcement that's where he had concerns
um just to not say general concerns he
wanted us to have a look at that in
fairness we haven't looked at planning
enforcement for a long time
so what we're trying to do in there is
looking at the resources
uh how their work is monitored how it's
distributed
uh and how it's prioritized so they're
some of the sort of areas that we would
want to look at and explore further
um with phil and his the enforcement
team as well
very good john thanks very much thank
you thank you coach lehren uh councillor
lindsay please
thank you chair um yeah just uh
pleased to see uh item uh
there's page 28 i believe item
5.5 um work on the environment priority
focuses on carrying out a health check
against the carbon reduction management
plan
um what does that what does that entail
please
so you just bear with me council
we scroll down to
page 28
yes it is page 28 yeah right yes
counselor so yeah
there to provide an objective assurance
to management and members for the key
risks are being managed effectively
accordance with the internal
and external obligations um
so my understanding having talking to
cassandra the assistant director
is there is a set of priorities
values that they hope to undertake in
terms of an action plan
and the idea is for my team
to have a word with cassandra
and her guys and actually do a health
check against the action plan to see
where we are
whether we're either ahead or behind the
ball and obviously to
to basically do a rag status against
that action plan
to establish exactly where we are where
we need to be
in terms of delivering on those action
plans
okay so there's no um it's not actually
looking at the amount of
carbon that the council's currently
admitting and
no unless it's um unless it's prescribed
actually within that action plan
then no it's just looking at the action
plans that were passed through
uh council and agreed by council that we
would actually do that health check
against
okay thank you thank you council lindsay
um do any other members have any
questions please
for uh john snow
[Music]
no then i will open up the item for
debate and
please could you use the raised hand
function please do any members wish to
debate this particular item further
thank you
no okay um the recommendation
is that the contents of the internal
audit report
supported by appendix a be noted now
there's no vote on this because say it's
purely being noted
um and i'd like to thank john for all
his work
on internal order and thank you very
much for the plans you've presented to
us today john
thank you very much thank you i'd like
no like to move on to item
number agenda number nine uh jac stroke
2015
statement of accounts and auditors
report for 2019-20
and i'd now like to invite rebecca
hewitt assistant manager financial
accountant
to present the report um
suresh are you also planning to comment
on that so
who would like to go to rebecca rebecca
first and then suresh
yeah thank you very much rebecca please
thank you rebecca
you're muted rebecca
sorry um i'd like to present to you
the uh the report for the statement of
the accounts 2019-20
and the auditor's report um
this year the audit is still continuing
um we have
um i think has given his audit report in
appendix a
and he will talk about that this morning
um in terms of issues that have arisen
so far
the only issue that could have an impact
on the
of or a financial implication for the
council relates to
community infrastructure levy as
highlighted in section 6.
for the statements of accounts are
attached to appendix
b and appendix c and so i shall hand
over to
suresh thank you thank you rebecca
um morning to members of the committee
um i've got my colleague vicky
chang as strong as i was with me who's
going to be um presenting part of this
so let me just give you a bit of an
introduction and an overall context and
then we'll we'll go into a bit of detail
in terms of some of the items that are
reporting
can you still hear me okay yes thank you
okay sorry
my screen froze for a second there um so
i suppose it's worthwhile just
reflecting on the fact that we're coming
up to the 31st of march
2021 and obviously the 1920 audi
is still in progress so be useful for me
to just to explain why that is the case
and it's worthwhile just be giving you a
bit of national context because
there's probably about 25 to 30 percent
of local authorities up and down the
country who
are in a similar position who have yet
to publish their audited 1920 accounts
and i think that's a reflection of how
challenging the uh the last 18 months
have been for both
preparers of local authority accounts as
well as as well as auditors clearly with
the impact of covid19
on not just the need to kind of work
remotely but also some particular
issues that is presented in terms of the
account so you'll see how
our reference to property valuations in
the report which we'll obviously give
you a bit of detail on
uh but also a reference to then
things like going concern and internal
consultations that we've had to do
to to satisfy ourselves that your
disclosures around those particular
areas
are are appropriate um we did we did
originally plan
to have the order completed by january
this year
so we did start the audit in november
through to december i think it's fair to
say
that again because of because of the
impact of covid
um the finance team has obviously had
priorities in terms of dealing with kobe
grants but also then
preparing the budget and i think the
timing of our audit is obviously
conflicted with that so that that has
contributed to the protracted nature of
the audit
and then the other angle is like i say
the particularly around property
valuations which i'm going to ask vicky
to talk about in a second
but if i take you to the um the
executive
summary which starts on page
41 of your pack i'll just talk through
some of the key messages there
so 41 just reminds you of the levels of
materiality that we
operate in terms of auditing the
statements of the two councils and the
two
two sets of group accounts uh over on
page 42 we give you a status of
where we were a few weeks ago in terms
of the audit a number of those areas up
in that first box
are now kind of complete the key areas
of working progress as i say is the
valuation of property plant and
equipment
um but also the reference to the
community infrastructure levy which
rebecca mentioned and vicky will
talk to you about that we've actually
completed some of our internal
consultation procedures our ongoing
concern
and valuation uncertainty so you will
see in the audit
auditor's report whilst we are giving
you and
proposing an unqualified opinion which
is obviously good news
we are including what's called an
emphasis and matter paragraph on
those valuations um those met that
material uncertainty that your valuer
has included in their evaluation report
that is not uncommon
for for 1920 where
councils have had significant levels of
assets that have been valued
using market activity data given the
volatility of the market as at the 31st
march 2020 most valuers across across
the country
have included a similar material
uncertainty paragraph and as a result
most auditors up and down the country
have included that paragraph in their
audit report and i should hasten to add
it's not
a qualification it's not a modification
it's actually just highlighting to the
to the reader of the accounts that
you've got that disclosure in your
accounts
uh over on page 43 we summarize their
the current uh what we call audit
differences that we've identified
there are as you see at the top of the
page um
some differences which the council is
happy not to adjust for
and that relates to the pension
liability
and what was called the mccloud case
which some of you might or might know
about but
in essence there's a national case
around pensions i think it was
to do agenda parity and the impact of
that on your pension liability is those
two figures there which obviously are
relatively small and we're content that
they don't need to be
corrected for um we've mentioned the
community infrastructure levy and
vicky can talk about that in terms of
what that means and and
in respect to the property evaluations
that is likely to lead to differences
which
was don't impact the bottom line of the
council clearly do have an impact the
balance sheets
page 44 we just summarized there our
work against the risks that we've
identified
and whilst i've said we're still working
on the property plans and equipment
things like the group accounts and now
the going concern disclosures
are are complete and we're happy with
those
uh over on page 45 it's useful to
highlight that
we have made some recommendations for
improvement in section 7 which vicki
will touch on
value for money we've given you a clean
bill of health in respect of
any matters to report that we don't have
any
and then over on page 46
i refer to some correspondence that we
did receive during the year
uh and i'll and i'll talk about that now
before coming back
to the fees after vicki's giving you an
update on on the property valuations but
on that correspondence i've included on
page 68
a bit more detail of what we received
uh what we did and what we found uh
essentially
the correspondence that we received was
asking us to look at the legality of
how the two councils have financed the
acquisition of properties
on behalf while cifco have acquired
properties particularly
there was one particular asset that that
was referenced in the correspondence
our focus was on has the council met the
relevant
uh mhclg and sifa requirements around
those acquisitions and how you fund
those
as you see there obviously a lot of this
is historic in terms of
when uh pacifico arrangement was
established
we were satisfied that you did receive
proper legal and treasury management
advice and you followed that
we're also satisfied that you complied
with the relevant requirements
in respective years uh in terms of how
you have financed those investments and
the disclosures
that you've made in things like your
joint capital investment and treasury
management strategies which
the most recent one includes clear
disclosure of
borrowing in need of advance so we were
satisfied that there was no
um illegal activity by the council in
respect of those transactions and those
funding
so we'll i'm sure there'll be questions
that i was happy to pick up in a second
but let me just pass on to vicky who
will talk you through
some the issues around property
valuations
thank you surash vikki over to you
thank you thank you chair and good
morning everyone
i'm i'm going to go through the property
plant and equipment valuations
and risk in terms of our work and the
findings to date
so i'm going to draw your attentions to
page
50 to 52 just to give you some
background about this risk
property plant and equipment is a
significant balance
in the financial statement and it
requires
material judgment and estimation
technique to calculate the year
imbalances
so a small movement in the assumption
used could have a mature impact on the
value
there has already been an increased
focus from regulator on reliance on
valuer
and the work they do so as a result this
requires us to have a more thorough
consideration of the approach to audit
and more extensive work on obtaining
the third party corporations for input
used by
the valuers and also the market data for
comparing
valuation and their basis
and this is even more so for paper and
be suffered due to a change of external
value
in 1920 and therefore property valuation
including investment property for faber
has been
identified as a significant risk set out
in our audit plan back in july
in addition the coveted pandemic also
triggered a material uncertainty
surrounding property valuation
which we also need to consider so in
order to address the risk
we have performed a number of procedures
and these are set out in
page 50. some of the additional
procedures that we have performed
including that we
consider the adequacy and scope of the
work performed by the external valuer
we engage ey real estate as our internet
specialist to review the assumptions and
methodology used by the valuer
we also consider the impact of any
material uncertainty relating to covet
19 on
all audit reports so in terms of the
sample size
on the general fund property asset we
selected a sample of 28 items for favor
and 29 for me suffered for testing
purpose
we also selected to test the sample of
136
for vapor and 103 for mix of
cancer dwellings and the work is still
in progress as russia just
mentions and but on the sample size
portions that was reviewed by
ui real estate we have already found a
number of
issues which we have set out in page 51.
some of the issues include um probably
full
asset valuation fell outside the
expected range and were potentially
overstated including the forehand gate
shopping center
for mid-september the initial findings
showed that the excellent valuer did not
have the complete or updated information
to carry out the valuations such as
different site plans for use in two
leisure center which do not reflect the
undeveloped land that are associated
with the site
the valuer was not make aware of the
part change of use in the former our
design and also on the four-year side
the valuer formed the evaluation based
on estimated gross income
without making any allowance for
opportunity operating expenses
so our further inquiries have also found
that
although this was the first year of the
council
engagement of his valuation specialists
with
hat and eve the valuer would not provide
all the relevant information during the
evaluation exercise
is that they were provided with the
prior year valuation information from
the former valuer
and so in our view this is a weakness in
the
valuation approach for 1920 for which we
have included our recommendation in
section
7 which is in page 71.
so from an audit perspective this
initial finding potentially could be a
significant issue
as we need to consider whether it also
impact on the rest of the asset
populations that were valued
so to give us the assurance that the
issue is not pervasive
across the general fund portfolio we
have
extended our testing criteria and have
asked for additional information for the
remaining sample size
to confirm that the correct site plan
were used
and the information on any actual plan
change in use of assets were private
to the valuer we are currently still
completing this additional testing
um and at the time of writing this
report
management have already obtained from
the external value with the revised
valuations for
form gate shopping center and the
mid-south leisure center
i wanted to update that we have now also
received the revised version for other
properties
including the stratbrook leisure center
former rd site and the four-year this
revised valuation are being reviewed and
considered by ui rare estate
currently so once we have completed our
procedures
we will need to follow our consultation
process uh relating to the material
uncertainties that were arising from
culvert 19
and our planned emphasis of matter in
our audit reports
with regarding to council dwelling we
also engaged eui reside to review the
work
subject to the final review the work has
been completed by ei real estate
with no matters to report our work on
the residual samples of council
dwelling is still in progress and we
will report our finding when the
complete
when the work is complete and
so i also wanted to flag the additional
audit time and
fees so due to the numbers of issues
that we have found
our order input in terms of resources
have been significantly higher than what
we
initially planned for including the
inputs from ui real estate
we have therefore included an estimate
of the addition of fee in section 8
which will be covered by thresh later
i would also like to draw your attention
to audit differences that we have
identified to date in page 63
which are the accounting treatment for
community infrastructure levy
in both council account and the exit
packages
in list of accounts so with regard to
the community infrastructure levy
the code requires any unspent um
charges to be recognized in the capital
grant's unapplied account
and also where the council act as a
collecting agent for parishes
the unpaid amount should be recognized
in creditors
however the council have incorrectly
recognized this amount all
in europe reserves and the error is
historic that dating back to 1718 and we
are currently waiting for the council
supporting working papers
to outline the proposed adjustment as
for the extra packages on missive
account we found a disclosure error
where the redundancy course and the
numbers of employees were not correctly
stated
because this relates to sensitive
information
we have also included a recommendation
in section 8
7 which are in page 71
where we have identified scope of um for
improvement in the three areas that i
have just mentioned
property valuations community
infrastructure levy and
exit so then just quickly then on the
fees as vikki just mentioned we've
included on page 74 and 75
our current position in terms of the
additional areas of work that we've had
to incur um
with a range i think for the um for the
work on property evaluations given that
he's still
in progress so it's finally len our our
plan at the moment
is that we hope to be able to complete
all the work
uh with the exception of the property
valuations by the end of april
and the reason why i say with the
exception of property valuations is
because that is dependent on how quickly
we get responses back from further
inquiries that i'm i'm sure our ebal
real estate specialist will have
if that in fact is you know imminent and
there's that quick turnaround then
clearly we'll we will hope to try and
wrap
everything up by the end of april but
might i suspect it will probably go into
may in terms of those valuation issues
but clearly we will
we'll work as quick as we can to get the
audit completed
and your accounts signed off we'll stop
there chair
we're happy to take any questions thank
you very much indeed suresh and also
to vicky um do any members have any
questions please counselor lindsay
please first
yes thank you chair um i suppose i've
got two
questions um one is just um
this property um errors
um and the sampling you did
what concerns me is i don't think you
look at the valuations under the
cifco um and and i just wonder if
if we've got these errors in the
properties we hold
kind of as baba and as mid suffolk uh
we're going to find the same areas in
valuations of properties that we bought
under cifco
and if so um what you know how do we
check
whether that's the case um and
the the second question was
um you know it's great that you've
picked this up
um i suppose the obvious question is
you know and but it's it's cost us a lot
of money for you to investigate it
so um um perhaps unfair question but why
didn't you pick it up before
thanks okay um i think in terms of the
the cifco question i think we we've
probably been asked about this before
about
that what you know the procedures we
carry out and uncycle clearly sifco
is consolidated into your group accounts
uh and we place reliance upon the
auditor
of pacifico in terms of the work they do
on asset valuation i'm not sure if they
use the same valuer
or it's the same approach in terms of
valuations but obviously
we've been testing the uh the
authorities
valuations and we have reviewed the work
of the auditor at cifco uh um
you know we haven't identified any
particular issues around the valuations
of those
assets but we wouldn't have done the
same level of testing that is a fair
fair fair point but we wouldn't expect
to either
in terms of the property valuations work
so um
obviously this this is the first year
of of your new valuation arrangement so
the basis that they value would have is
different to the basis of valuation
particularly around assumptions than
that your prior
valuer has adopted the key issue
is the information that that your
current valuer has used
to inform those valuations and as vicky
said they were using the previous year's
data and obviously things have moved on
around some of those
some of those assets um so so that's the
reason why we wouldn't have picked that
up in the prior year
it's also worth saying that um the
valuations of property assets at local
authorities is
is a big area of focus for the kind of
regulators of auditors
and you're not uncommon as an authority
to have issues with
the valuations your assets quite a lot
of uh quite a lot of the reasons why
there's only still like i say 25 30 of
councils that still need to publish
their
1920 accounts audited is because of
valuation issues
uh it is an area of focus for auditors
each year
we're required to do even more than we
have done in the past
so sorry if i if i could just check what
i've
what you just said make sure i've
understood it the
the reason it wasn't picked up before is
because it's only the last year that we
changed the
the valuer for 1920 yeah
yeah okay okay thank you
thank you council lindsey uh councillor
matheson please yeah
i i i've got two or three questions
just staying with with where we are at
the moment so to speak
um so this might be a question
for from for our own officers uh
who who decided to change the value
and what was the reasons
i think there's a question for officers
chair i think it is
is that one for catherine or for rebecca
or melissa
please let's like i'll let
chair i'll try and answer initially but
melissa may want to come in
um it obviously was before rebecca
joined us so it wouldn't be fair to put
rebecca on the spot in terms of that of
that question
um we felt it was time for a change in
terms of having the valuer
um it's a very small organization we
previously
used the district valuer and we found
they weren't a big enough organization
to actually undertake
our work when we needed it to be done
and were
not always responsive in terms of us
needing
additional information from them so they
often had an impact on our timetable
in terms of closing the accounts and
being able to meet our
statutory deadlines to to achieve a
closure of accounts
so we made the decision to to test the
market
and to to look at changing our value
value as for the
this year's accounts um i'll just pause
there in case uh melissa wanted to add
anything
uh on top of that no totally agree with
that thanks catherine
yeah if i could continue with with that
that thread
first chair um i i think the
and this is perhaps more back for suresh
um obviously with with the protracted
delays and so on
which we you know to some extent
understand
um although i must say from what you
said
we are in the bottom quarter of the
performance of councils then um
alas um but what i was wondering about
really was that the um
you know that whether we we should
somehow be focusing rather more on
getting good valuations and every
getting everything right
because the year ends on wednesday
the year 2021 it ends on wednesday this
week
um and um you know are we going to have
um ironed out all
all the the you see you've been
outlining
or both you've been outlining uh with
the valuation side
um so that it's all
it all comes out smoothly and
reliable et cetera et cetera um
for 2021.
so so i think maybe kathleen can update
yeah on what you're doing for this
currently but from
just from our perspective obviously i
think i think this has been
good learning i suspect for the for for
the council in terms of the issues that
we've identified and i know
there's been a lot of work done already
with your value and the information that
they've now got
so um you know i think i think we've
made a recommendation i think the
finance team have accepted that and are
are are doing are taking action to make
improvements
thank you so much cathy would you like
to come in there please yeah if i could
just add to that
chair obviously um you're just hearing
about this at the committee today but
we've been working with the auditors for
a number of weeks now
around the issues around the uh ppe
valuations
so you know we've had time to think
about what we need to do differently
towards the
the 2021 accounts uh and definitely it's
been valuable learning that we'll put
into
practice for for the valuations for the
current financial year
thank you catherine councillor matheson
do you have a further question please
um yeah it was quite
quite quite a different point though on
the um
i mean it may just be that this is the
what the government says end of story
but on the
community infrastructure levy um the
five percent for administration
obviously i should say up to five
percent for administration
um what what's worrying me is
is actually that the the cost
that the administration work um
is substantially lags behind
the collecting of the money um and we've
we've now built up
you know a large a large pile of money
actually
um and and we're waiting for various
infrastructure providers to to
to bid for that and all right we paid
out a few million now
but um if the
if the five percent is is
at the time that the money is being
collected
that's not when we're going to need to
spend the money on the administration so
i don't can we is there no way of
actually putting that into a reserve or
something
um for for the um you know
because i i you know haven't had some
involvement in now in it
we there is a lot of work
down the down the way once we've
actually received a bid
um and that is that that's a long time
after when
when the the the five percent was not
needed if you see what i mean
because you know where you've said we've
we've we've taken five percent we should
have taken less than that because we
didn't we
we didn't spend so much
do you see the point i'm looking for
there
catherine is that one that you you could
answer possibly please
um i'll try to chair um
i think um probably the point here
is that um christine thurlow's team
is obviously the team that does
administer the the sill
on behalf of the two councils um she has
a
a team and their costs and i think the
point is
uh councillor matheson that probably if
christine finds that she doesn't have
enough um support within her team then
she would obviously
you know talk within the council to see
if more resource could be provided
if you're suggesting you know that there
will be higher demands in future
and if that is still within the five
percent
of the seal that we're collecting in
that particular year then
yes we could use the five percent to to
support that
um i'm not sure if that entirely answers
your question but but does that help in
some way
well yeah up to a point i mean i'm
i'm conscious of the fact that
government tend to
change these schemes all the while all
right it's perhaps not
quite as vulnerable as something like
the new homes bonus
but um they do change these things and
they change the rules and so on and and
i'm just wondering that if we
if if we you know only spend two percent
instead of five percent
and then put the rest of the money into
the pot and decide to spend it
um then we might actually then finish up
with it with a substantial
extra cost later on in in
um as i said spend it spending the money
so to speak
uh yeah it's just recognizing that that
the rules don't seem to actually reflect
how
how the thing really is really working
that's all that but well
we maybe leave it there that seems to me
there's a bit of an issue
thank you counselor matheson thank you
catherine uh councillor mccraw please
thank you
you're beautiful that's cool
start again your music oh it's better
thank you it's
a delay i have no idea why this should
happen but that's the way it is
um actually i think i'd like to address
the sill question
uh because the still accounting uh
changes
necessary would seem to me to apply for
the fact that we start
off with the five percent as a basic
assumption for that will be the cost
of administering sill and then his as it
has been referred to
historically um it emerges that in fact
in this instance the cost has been less
than the assumed five percent
and uh inevitably because you can't know
in advance
that's where this modification and the
accounting impact comes in
but what i'd like to ask about is uh
from page 34 where the impact is first
mentioned
by rebecca and then vicky on page 63
these adjustments being historical can i
ask
where they would be applied in
correcting the accounts
and what the potential impacts would be
on future budgets
or uh the existing budget or would we be
looking at
previous years
thank you would that be one for
catherine to answer please or rebecca
i think this one might be one for for
rebecca or melissa to answer
thank you chad thank you melissa
would you like to take that one over
again yep i can
i can do um we have had to go back to
previous years to look at the the
figures for
seal um so there will be some financial
implications
and that's still being worked through
um it may be that that sue can provide
us a
short update of of where that is but
that we have had to go back to sort of
2016-17 i think
to to look at look at that um i don't
know if you're able to update sue
thank you uh yes we are working through
the figures
and the fact that we've had to go back a
couple of years
has obviously meant uh quite a bit of uh
work and
detailed work to do we are getting to
the point
where we've analyzed what should have
happened
and we're looking at what has happened
so that we can then work out what the
differences are
and to work out what what the
adjustments are to
to the these statements and um
the figures in the general ledger so
we're nearly there
but uh not quite thank you sue
can i just take a follow-up i'm sorry i
was just going to add to that i mean in
terms of adjustment
for baber we'll likely have to look at
the transformation
fund balance to do the adjustment with
and probably similarly with mid suffolk
it will be through the the growth and
efficiency fund
but we'll sort of make that decision
once we know what the final figures are
looking like
well my follow-up question was would
that would we be expecting
any impact on the uh budgets that we've
just passed this year
for the 2021 to 22 period
yeah i i've asked that question myself
because that popped into my head when
the issue arose and and i believe that
we have set
the budget for 2122 in the right way
so that it shouldn't be an impact for
the cup for the coming year
possibly 22 to 23
i was going to say we will look at look
at it now each year
and you know apply the the right
methodology to the budgets moving
forward
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you catherine thank you uh councilman
crawl
uh counselor mclaren please
thank you chair uh my question is
i just want some clarification of what
vicky said
and then i can ask the question after
that so just confirm what you said vicky
in your report about the sell payments
did you what what was it you actually
said about the payments to parishes did
you say
it was late or it hadn't happened
um now um thank you for the questions
so the the seal charges that um
paying to the parishes is basically the
council actually
acting to collect this money for the
parishes as well
so not just for the sales so for any
payments that you know
um um that needs to pass on to the
parishes
the council actually will receive those
income
and then hold up in the account and pay
them you know in the due course
when the um development commences so
that's how
it should work so therefore for this
portion of the money it should be
recognized as a creditors because
i understand yes yeah thank you very
much thank you chair
thank you councillor mclaren uh
councillor lindsay please
thank you chair um just again just to
return to the property evaluations and
cifco
um perhaps i could ask the officers
because
suresh didn't know who the um value was
at cisco and if it was the same
as the value we have for our main
properties
so um so first question is
for the officers is is the value of the
saying for cisco
um the second question is who is the
auditor for cifco
and the third question is um are the
officers satisfied that
um that the audit that we're getting of
cifco
um is picking up um
you know is is accurate and that there
isn't a similar problem
in cifco and or do we need to
ask our auditors to do a similar
exercise
to what ernst young has done thank you
thank you
catherine please yes thank you chair
um i don't believe the valuer is the
same
valuer um that we use for the council's
main accounts
we think it might be frank knight that
he's used
but obviously cifico is a joint venture
so it has its own board and the board
are the people who appoint both the
valuers and the auditors
for for sifco so say that's got its own
arrangements um i believe that ensors
are the auditors for for the accounts
for for cifco
um so say they are appointed
independently
by by the board of sifco so
they would obviously be having their own
conversations obviously
the ensembles also have to do a report
to the sifko board
on their accounts i'm not quite sure of
the timing of that and when that is
discussed
but obviously that would be available
once that that audit has been completed
and and the account submitted a
company's house
it might be a conversation to have with
emily attack who's obviously sits on the
board of of cifco if you wanted further
information
about those arrangements
thank you catherine uh okay so lindsay
did you want a supplementary question
please
well it's perhaps one for us as a
committee but
do we want to write to the board of
um the board of civco and um
make them aware of the issues we have
with our own
valuations here
um okay thank you
catherine i think um whether that might
be useful i think you know
to satisfy members this committee if we
can have a report from
from um emily attack for a future
reference
i'm happy to speak to emily and find out
where they're at with their audit of the
accounts and whether they had similar
issues or not
and yes i can i can circulate that back
to the members of the committee
that'd be very much appreciated thank
you very much thank you council lindsay
for your question
um suresh did you want to come back
please yeah just to sort of follow up on
that part i think it's
worthwhile um just being clear so i
totally accept
it's a valid question to ask about you
know the appropriateness of valuations
in cifco
but the way you consolidate cifco into
your group accounts which is
what you've got in front of you means
that those valuations really are i won't
say irrelevant but
you don't you don't bring the assets
onto your group accounts
they're kind of they're basically not
part of the consolidation
if there's any movement in those
valuations that might feed through but
uh but the actual value of those assets
doesn't sit in your group accounts
thank you suresh uh cash number crawl
please
i'm not sure my microphone is on it is
oh good it's not showing um whether that
might
beyond be beyond the remit not only of
the auditors for
the council but also beyond the remit of
this committee
i'm quite happy obviously i've looked at
pacifico quite a lot over the
entire years of its operation and
it would seem to me that the uh
questions on the sifko account
should be addressed through sithko's
meetings or
scrutiny of cifco um and a separate
audit
of sifko it would be um something that
could be
questioned in the sithko annual meeting
uh that's just from a point of view of
procedure that i've observed over the
years
thank you councilman that's quite a good
point um catherine
was there anything you could perhaps add
to that at all please
so on on this occasion i might need to
defer to our monitoring officer on that
one chair thank you
um can i bring in emily please to um
perhaps comment on that
thank you emily thank you chair i was i
was just actually looking
at the last um annual report
of sifko to the full council and can
confirm that the
um auditors and the valuers that
catherine remembered
um from memory were correct so
that was pretty impressive um chair i
would just like to to
make that point that the um the cifco
report in terms of the performance
report and the business plan does come
to council
on an annual basis that's normally in
july um and that's an opportunity
obviously for the cat the full council
to
scrutinize and ask questions around the
work of
sifko um i
don't really see a connection in the
valuation issue that um our auditors
have
have found in respect of the council's
assets
i don't see a connection with the assets
of cifco
but there's no reason why we couldn't
share our observations with the board of
sifko but i i don't see a direct
correlation between the two
um and indeed i don't think it would be
um appropriate in terms of the
governance arrangements for cifco to ask
for additional information to come back
to the joint audit and standards
committee because we already have
the scrutiny process established um and
as i say that actually does come to full
council so all counselors can
comment on it yeah really appreciate
that emily thank you very much indeed
thank you
uh counselor matheson please yeah i i i
just wanted to understand
a little more what suresh was just
saying about
sifko valuation in our consolidated
group
accounts balance sheet which that is an
asset
of or half of it is an asset of
mid-suffolk
um so so it's the valuation must be in
there somewhere
vicky to give you a bit more detail but
in essence you adopt what's called
equity accounting so you
you account for your share of the
uh in effect the kind of profit and loss
of those entities rather than
the assets that they hold vicki did any
more you can
add no um basically that's
equity accounting is basically you just
recognize
the profit and loss in sql accounts
so um each paper and this support will
take their share and recognize in your
sync
entity cies your comprehensive income
and expenditure account
so so but the balance sheet i mean
how does that work where does where does
the the
the um unfortunate at the moment deficit
um of cifco where does that rest in in
the
in the group accounts of of mid-suffolk
because you recognize that in your
single entity cies
so when you transfer um consolidated
into your group account
it will actually recognize in your
reserve so
on the um usable reserve in your group
balance sheet
i mean i i assume that you know um
sue or rebecca probably we can give you
a bit more details behind that
on the accounting treatment but it is
currently sitting in your group balances
under the reserve usable reserves
okay well i've been interested to learn
a little bit more about how that
how that actually is done um but perhaps
outside this meeting thank you yes i
agree thank you thank you very much
vicky
thank you counselor matheson um do any
other members have any questions at this
stage
no um then i will now open up for debate
uh please use the raised hand function
for the debate
please do any members wish to debate
this item
i take that as a no okay then
i'd like to move on to the
recommendations of paragraphs
three one two three four within the
report
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 are for both
councils
recommendation 3.3 is for baby
councillors only
and recommendation 3.4 is for
mid-suffolk councillors only
um can i have a proposer and a second to
please for
uh recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 please
could we have the page number chair very
helpfully
the page number was probably
hang on uh 33 is it
33 i've got 33 and 34.
let's have a look at those
oh yes thank you yeah
so are you looking to propose counselor
matheson
for items 3.1 and 3.2
occasionally the crawl please i'd like
to propose
motions recommendations three point one
and three point two for both councils
thank you counselor crawl catch the
huron
okay so haran i think you're still muted
my apologies no problem that didn't seem
to work yes um i will second um
therefore said numbers yep thank you
very much i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please
thank you thank you chair so this is for
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2
of the report so this is for all members
if you can go to
the modern.gov app
open the agenda go to the plus sign
and attendance and voting this vote
should be in progress
[Music]
just waiting for a couple more bites
uh thank you chair so all the votes are
in that's eight votes four and one
against
thank you very much uh mandy uh
councillor huron did you have a question
please
your hand's just gone up uh no sorry
it's an old hand chairman
i'll take it down in a mirror thank you
very much
um right i'd like to move on to
recommendation 3.3 which only baby
councillors can vote on
can i have a proposer and a seconder for
recommendations 3.3 please from the baby
members please yes chair i'd be willing
to um
um recommend that thank you thank you
very much lehren and councillor mccraw
did you have we're going to second i'd
like to second that please
and counselor fraser was that that was
that you were going to second as well
were you
yeah clearly not in faster than the uh
okay thank you very much could i ask
mandy to
conduct the electronic vote please for
the baba members 3.3
thank you thank you chair that vote is
now in progress
baba members please
uh okay i think i've received all votes
yeah so that would be um
oh sorry my screen's just frozen
i think that's unanimous chair thank you
very much uh mandy
um i'd now like to um
propose the recommendation 3.4 for uh
mid-suffolk councillors
and i'm happy to propose that uh
counselor matheson did you wish to
second that
no i i really wanted to understand
whether the the
the account the accounts had actually
been completed um
if we sound as if we're still dealing
with the audit of them
um are they in fact complete
i believe they're still in being
completed i believe that's
that's the correct um suresh or
catherine
what i read so you obviously issued your
draft accounts which will be you need to
be updated
for the findings that we've been talking
about so
and that so we haven't got a final
version because they haven't been
revised yet yeah
that's how i understood it yeah well
frankly
you know i wouldn't want to vote without
qualifying what's written in 3.4
then if it's not if it's not done it's
not done
um can i
can i help chair yes please catherine
yep
uh we're asking for the final sign off
for the final version of the accounts
for delegation to myself and the two
chairs of the committee
so what the committee is being asked to
vote for in 3.3 and 3.4
now for mid suffolk is that um you
approve that we do sign them off once
once they are completed so it's that
delegation
can we can we actually say that in in
the in the recommendation please
i mean i i don't want to be pedantic or
anything but i mean
you know let's let's if that's what
we're doing that we should
say that's what we're doing i mean we
are in some pretty difficult times here
um you know signing off something a year
after the event
uh except that we're we're we're signing
off but it's not actually
complete so all right i would
be moderately comfortable to delegate
accordingly but let's please say
that we're delegating in i'm sorry to
delay things but
i that's how i feel about it if anyone
else agrees with me
on the mid-south side well then um
if i could assist again looking at the
recommendations in the report
3.1 is asking for the the delegation
and then it said that this delegation
will include
that once complete the joint external
auditor's report and then again once
complete
the final accounts so the three point
two and the three point three for baber
and the three point four for
mid suffolk are what's being included in
the delegation
yes i so you're saying that that that so
they are
all yeah i see yes i i've
i spot the colon there this will include
colon three point three four
yeah that's how i understood the
situation that's how i answer that
is there anything else so do you wish to
second all right well i
yeah having had that explained then i i
will second it
okay thank you very much um did um
counselor harold did you wish to make a
comment before we go to the vote on that
one
no i think it's an old handshake thank
you
um right could i ask the governor's
officer please to conduct the vote on
3.4 please thank you so mid-suffolk
members that vote should now be in
progress
for you
just waiting for one more vote
thank you chair that's unanimously for
thank you very much
mandy right therefore i'd no like to
move on to item number 10 which is jac20
stroke 16
the complaints monitoring report and i'd
now like to invite emily rule
emily ewell the monitoring officer to
present the report please over to you
emily please thank you
thank you chairman i'm pleased to
introduce the code of conduct
complaints monitoring report um chair i
would just like to apologize for some
typos in an earlier version of the
report
in respect of the dates in the headings
of the table
and some incorrect years were printed
but it has been
amended now thank you
thank you this is a statistical report
detailing the number of code of conduct
complaints received in the period first
of november 2020
to 18th of march 2021
i cannot go into the detail of any
individual complaints
due to the privacy rights of both the
complainant
and the subject of the complaints
however i would like to provide the
committee with some further contextual
background there has been a particularly
high volume of complaints
on the baby side 55 complaints were
received
10 about district councillors and 45
about town and parish councillors in the
period reported
the town and parish council complaints
are predominantly related to
long melford parish council and hadley
town council
in both cases there have been particular
events that have generated multiple
and sometimes reciprocal complaints
i and my team are working closely with
these councils to provide support
and i have recently written formally to
hadley town council with some
recommendations
including that i now attend all full
council meetings
to deal with any conduct issues at the
time they arise
a large number of the complaints
continue to relate to comments made on
social media
and we are eagerly awaiting the guidance
on the new
lga model code of conduct to see if
there will be greater powers given to
monitoring officers to intervene
when social media posts are made from a
personal account
seven complaints about town and parish
councillors have been upheld during this
period
and recommendations have been made
regarding appropriate sanctions
these have included attendant training
making a formal apology
and reviewing the policies of the
councils involved
to give greater clarity to both staff
and
counsellors chairman i'm happy to answer
any queries on the report but would just
remind councillors again that i cannot
go into the detail of any individual
complaints
thank you thank you very much emily do
we have any questions from members for
emily please
counselor horan please
yes thank you chair thank you emily um
am i correct in thinking that if
somebody has complained again spit
district or parish are they alerted to
the fact they are
um have been complained against or is it
totally kept private
chairman if it depends on the nature of
the complaint
and the stage at which the the complaint
gets to
so um there will be cases where
a complaint doesn't um get through
initial assessment because it doesn't
meet
the criteria to be counted as a code of
conduct complaint
so in some cases we wouldn't inform the
subject of the complaint
um because it's it's not actually a
formal code of conduct complaint it's
been dismissed at the initial assessment
stage
and in some cases uh the complainant has
requested anonymity as well so
um we wouldn't share those details but
any time
that a code of conduct complaint is
um treated as a formal complaint within
the
the scope of the code of conduct
complaints procedure
the counsellor is informed regardless of
whether
that complaint is then upheld or
dismissed after investigation
thank you thank you council councillor
mclaren please
thank you thank you emily um
obviously the difference between the two
councils was very marked
and um i'm glad you sort of advised us
of
where the majority probably were
centered um but i've just one question
the the complaints against district
councillors
is the i don't know whether i can ask
this question or not
um is are many of the complaints
raised by other district councillors or
is it from the general public
thank you for your question councillor
the the source of the complaints
is i would say fairly split between
complaints by other councillors
and complaints from from members of the
public um
albeit obviously that that has no impact
on how we
deal with the complaint um all
complainants are are treated
in the same manner yeah thank you emily
thank you joe
thank you council mclaren uh counselor
mccraw please
this is working
can you hear me we can hear you yeah
that's something
um it's been a difficult year um
to put it mildly and i suspect that uh
for controversial issues
and for tensions running high with a lot
of frustration
that needs to be vented it's maybe not
too surprising to see an increase
in these complaints that's a comment and
it's not a question so i'll come to the
question
on the matter of the social media um
aspects
to this and i think it's absolutely
crucial
um in the current circumstances the code
of conduct you referred to
emily that's going to be produced by the
local government association
um am i correct in thinking both
councils provided a very clear response
to that consultation pointing out well
actually perhaps emily you could run
through
what the nature of our response was on
behalf of both councils
uh regarding social media and its
prevalent use thank you council
emily please yeah thank you chairman um
yes you're right the the councils both
responded to
the um consultation on the new model
code
um that was developed by the local
government association um
uh back in the autumn of last year
with regards to social media the
councils were very clear that the code
needed to provide greater clarity about
acceptable behaviour on social media
and also to tackle this uh
the current presumption in in respect of
capacity so
when we consider code of conduct
complaints we have to establish capacity
which is
is essentially the question was the
counsellor acting in an official
capacity
when the behavior occurred and in the
case of social media quite
often personal social media accounts are
um are used to make comments
and therefore the capacity test is
difficult to
um to satisfy so quite often we find
that we're unable to apply the code
because
we're unable to prove that the comments
were made in an official capacity
because a personal account has been used
and so the consultation response also
um sought clarity and and
um sort of a uh
a firmer position on the presumption of
of
official capacity now those haven't been
brought through
into the published um revised model code
of conduct so
a revised code has been published and is
available for adoption
by councils um but um in my viewing and
and also
in the view of uh many other monitoring
offices across the country
because there's been no legislative
change the amendments to the new model
code are actually quite
minor and therefore we are awaiting um
guidance that is currently being
produced for the lga
that will provide further context about
how that new model code can be applied
and at that point i think it would be
appropriate for me to then bring that
model code to to the council and
establish
whether it's the council's wish to adopt
all or parts of the new model code
and of course chair um a really
important part of that is maintaining
our suffolk wide local code of conduct
so i am working very closely with
monitoring officers
um at the county and in the other
districts and the borough council
thank you emily uh council mccraw do you
have a supplementary question i do if i
may
thank you might we see that uh code of
conduct
for the use of social media be brought
to the council and
are we expecting it to make any points
regarding
uh use of social media from the public
i know that's not within our remit or
our control but on the other hand i
think
we we have a responsibility to try and
produce civilized
conversations and discourse and if we
don't acknowledge that
we can't expect people to uh make up
their own minds without that guidance
uh chair there is some um discussion or
mixed information about when we're
expecting to to get that guidance
initial
indications um whether it would be
produced in the latter half of the
summer
and there's now some suggestion that the
lga of our stack to be brought forward
to may
so that councils could adopt the revised
code
at the annual council meetings um
however i think given that the time
the the time of the year that we're
already at and uh
given the um challenges of um
getting something produced and consulted
and and shared with councillors before
the annual council meeting i think it's
very unlikely that
weber and mid-suffolk councils would be
looking at it in the in at the annual
council meetings
um so i'd expect it to come to council
uh maybe july or
or september uh realistically um
it just in regard to the query around
public use of social media there is no
way that um the code of conduct or
councils can regulate public
use um however there is
um guidance and support for councillors
uh around how to respond or how to
ignore perhaps
um comments made on social media
particularly
um comments made by trolls or other very
um distressing comments that sometimes
occur
and um i'd just like to kind of take the
opportunity to remind all councillors
that
um the democratic services team are
there to provide that support and
and um direct you to to guidance
documents around that
thank you thank you emily thank you yeah
that's the better do it better do it
right
rather than early absolutely yeah thank
you
michael uh council mclaren please thank
you chair
um emily can i just ask this report
does it become an agenda item for
cabinet
no it's um the the remit for um
looking at code of conduct complaints
sits with um the joint audit and
standards committee
okay thank you for that clarification
thank you chair
thank you very much um do we have any
further questions from members please
no therefore um i will now open up the
item for debate
so if anybody would like to debate this
item can you please raise
your hand please
no i don't think we've got any debate
therefore the recommendation is
that the code of conduct complaints
monitoring information contained in
paper
jac stroke 20 stroke 16 be noted there's
no need for a vote
on this particular one so thank you
emily for your report
um can we now move on to agenda item 11
which is
jack 2017 the forward plan
are there any suggestions comment or
amendment on the forward plan please
please use the raise hand function
uh catherine please
thank you chair um yes if i could just
mention
that um we have got some changes to make
to the forward plan we had been working
behind the scenes for an updated version
but unfortunately i think the version
that's in the pack today isn't the
updated version that we had been working
on
um so i believe i see mandy's popped on
the screen as well i think mandy is
going to circulate
the revised version to councillors after
the meeting this morning
what i was just going to say was just to
confirm what is on
there there for your may meeting
obviously that's your next
meeting so the items that are on there
for the may meeting is the joint
audit plan for 2021
the annual audit letter for 2019-20
there will be the annual internal audit
report the backward looking for 2021
the joint annual governance statement
for 2021
the esg investment report
that was requested and then if
necessary any constitutional update or
complaints monitoring report from the
monitoring officer
thank you very much thank you counselor
matheson please
yeah yeah i i um
catherine did just say joint audit plan
so
so that the the date's been corrected on
that first item then
you're saying is it
i was just looking at what's originally
there and it says 1920 but you said 2021
and i
like to think you're probably right yes
yes because it's
uh 2021 audit of accounts counsellor yes
right
that's fine thank you chair if i can
just come in and apologize
for the report that was uh circulated
and i
um as catherine has said that we have
been working in the background
and that updated forward plan will be
with members
later on this afternoon thank you very
much mandy more than happy for that
thank you for that um therefore if there
are no further questions um
this concludes the meeting so i'd like
to thank suresh and vicky and all
officers and members for attending this
morning the next meeting is currently
scheduled for the 17th
of may commencing at 9 30. so thank you
everybody
for attending this morning and i wish
you all a good day
you